[Musique]
lutter contre le harcèlement c'est le
projet scolaire porté par huit classes
de 6e au collège de bras panon pendant
une année
ces élèves ont travaillé et identifier
les situations de harcèlement à
appréhender les rôles de chacun et
connaître les moyens de se protéger
il ya eu des ateliers éducatifs qui ont
été menées directement donc au sein des
classes avec eux on va dire deux heures
mensuelles
ils ont participé à la journée dont du
harcèlement et la rencontre avec des
travailleurs sociaux parce que le
conseil départemental oeuvre autour de
la protection de l'enfance donc montrer
aux enfants comment on assure justement
leur protection au quotidien et comment
on travaille avec l'enfant et avec sa
femme
la conclusion de cette année de travail
s'est aujourd'hui avec ce forum du mieux
vivre ensemble à travers différents
ateliers animés par des professionnels
ces collégiens ont reproduit des scènes
de harcèlement l'objectif étant entre
autres d'apprendre à gérer ses émotions
et faire de la médiation dans le but de
résoudre ses conflits
il ya des gens qui ont moins de chance
que nous parce qu'il ya des gens qui
sont harcelés tous les jours et que
c'est difficile pour eux et ça nous a
permis de sensibiliser les personnes
lésées disent ils ont un problème
quelque chose comme ça dans le parler
parce que ça sert à rien de tout garder
pour pour eux et ça leur coûterait entre
1 pouces le magne apprend à 12 ans
les choses qui ne vont pas et leur
expliquer que inboard par apple il faut
oser parce qu'il ya des mauvais
agissements des commandes est lourdement
et qu'à travers le témoignage
ça peut être une aide apportée le
harcèlement un phénomène de société
aujourd'hui un jeune sur huit seraient
victimes de harcèlement physique ou
morale
[Musique]